[Musique]
l'ukraine du président hélène ce qui ne
relâche pas la pression sur auchan
nouvelle étape avec un appel au boycott
du ministre des affaires étrangères
ukrainien
apparemment des pertes d'emplois en
russie sont plus importantes que des
pertes humaines en ukraine moi je
conseillerais à monsieur et lynch qui
avec tout le respect qu'on lui doit
plutôt que de faire campagne contre
auchan de demander aux allemands de
réouvrir les centrales nucléaires qui
est donc cette ligne 1 de demander aux
belges d'ouvrir la centrale nucléaire
qui vient de fermer ça ferait peut-être
baisser la dépendance par rapport au
gatt le boycott nous on pense que c'est
une arme utile à je vous le dis
aujourd'hui par rapport à israël qui
impose un apartheid contre le peuple
palestinien ou par rapport à des tas de
dictature en fait d'état scio ça se pose
de problème mais même la france qui vend
des armes à l'arabie saoudite
la france qui soutient des dictatures en
afrique nous donnons aux russes 720
millions d'euros par jour pour financer
leur guerre donc moi je veux bien qu'on
aille manifesté devant leroy merlin ou
chance ça fait plaisir ça permet d'avoir
une bonne conscience sur les pme
françaises qui risque de se faire
racheter à vil prix ou qui risquent de
faire faillite alors je ne donnerai pas
de leçons de morale parce que je pense
qu'il faut penser aussi à leurs salariés
chacun
vous voyez la seule question vous posez
c'est est-ce que je valide
lui il dit qu'il n'a pas entendu et
qu'il condamne ça vous suffit comme
explication écoutez il faut lui laisser
je pense le bénéfice du doute dans cette
affaire mais c'est vrai que c'était pas
très intelligent pour tous ces gens-là
de crier ce genre de slogan parce qu'à
dire macro à sa son nom mais justement
vu je vous le dis moi c'est un raccourci
que je ne ferai pas voilà mais c'est
vrai que je pense que l'état du monde et
la situation complètement catastrophique
la déliquescence des états le y compris
le financement d'ailleurs d'un certain
nombre de groupes armés par les grandes
puissances les états unis on s'est quand
même comment est née al qaïda ben laden
et ses sponsorisé par la cia eric
zemmour un discours qui attisent la
violence il n'est pas capables de la
contrôler or un président de la
république doit maîtriser ses supporters
et aujourd'hui on à eric zemmour qui est
totalement discréditée à côté
il ya les projets de la droite deux
prêts et créances et de matt rand as oui
alors qui a copié l'autre
je pense que ce n'est pas très important
d'ailleurs qu'ils aillent se disputaient
leurs droits d'auteur il n'est pas
illégitime que les français commencent
sérieusement à s'inquiéter de voir une
classe politique au premier rang des
quais de laquelle le président la
république est incapable de prendre des
mesures d'autorité contre des
délinquants et des criminels qui
menacent nos enfants nos filles nos
femmes nos mères pour ya deux hypothèses
la première c'est l'indignité est plutôt
celle d'une femme la plus crédible
ce n'est pas une surprise la deuxième
c'est la méconnaissance d'une réforme
très importante du quinquennat c'est le
100% santé et maintenant les prothèses
auditives les lunettes et les prothèses
dentaires sont remboursés par la
sécurité sociale d'autant qu'on sait que
le sujet du handicap a déjà été un
problème dans cette campagne
souvenez-vous d'ailleurs avec eric
zemmour et jean luc mélenchon un débat
où eric zemmour disait à jean luc
mélenchon qui n'avait pas entendu ou
malentendu une de ses phrases il faut
quand même bien entendre et jean luc
mélenchon il avait répondu mais moi je
suis déficients auditifs partiel
j'invite alors à ce moment là le
candidat malentendants à pouvoir
s'équiper à moindre frais et bien moi je
dirais que là c'est la capitale de
l'estonie et lhassa la capitale de la
lituanie celle inverse voilà autant pour
moi manuel macron devrait faire des
meetings devant autant de monde à
l'extérieur il comprendrait qu'on
n'entend pas donc cci là il n'a pas
encore l'habitude il a pas où il
n'arrive pas à réunir autant de monde
vous m'aider dans l'union européenne
mais ça fait partie du vélo